[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre 7 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 20 septembre
la visite du roi d'Angleterre au château
de Versailles Charles III diderera avec
Emmanuel Macron dans la galerie des
Glaces quel est le menu qui va cuisiner
qui sont les invités quel est le
protocole d'une visite royale on fait le
point dans cette émission et ce mercredi
20 septembre c'est aussi la Journée
européenne de la prostate l'occasion de
sensibiliser aux différentes pathologies
liées notamment au cancer de la prostate
chez les hommes on en parle avec le
docteur Sandra genevois
urologue à Versailles au programme
également ce soir le coup de cœur cinéma
d'un professionnel du septième art le
réalisateur yvelinois Quentin Dupuis
nous parle du fameux film Le Parrain de
Francis Ford Coppola et puis comme
d'habitude l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième
partie d'émission avec Thomas gourland
le président de l'agglomération de
Rambouillet territoire nous parle de la
journée du développement durable qui
aura lieu ce samedi 23 septembre à La
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
ce matin régnait un parfum d'excitation
à la British School of Paris
dans quelques heures les élèves de cet
établissement installés à
Croissy-sur-Seine vont vivre un instant
unique avoir la possibilité d'approcher
le roi Charles III en visite en France
ils étaient une cinquantaine à prendre
le départ des Yvelines vers 11h30
direction la capitale je pense qu'on a
vraiment hâte parce qu'on va vraiment
voir
l'Alliance française anglaise et c'est
une belle représentation de nos deux
pays qui soient amis et
toute l'histoire qui a derrière
on ne sait pas si on va pouvoir le
rencontrer mon espère vraiment le voir
et échanger avec lui on espère qu'en
voyant les enfants tous en uniforme il
viendra peut-être nous voir avec la
reine Camille les élèves ont assisté cet
après-midi à la cérémonie de ravivage de
la Flamme et de dépôts de gerbe sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu sous l'Arc de
Triomphe ils étaient également aux
premières loges pour le défilé du roi
Charles III et de la reine Kamila sur
les Champs-Élysées après un entretien au
Palais de l'Élysée avec Emmanuel Macron
la journée du monarque anglaise s'achève
ce soir dans les Yvelines un dîner
d’état sera donné dans la galerie des
Glaces du château de Versailles avec un
menu Royal servi pour l'occasion en
entrée du homard bleu et tourteaux de
casier réalisé par la chef Anne-Sophie
Pic le plat principal de la volaille de
Bresse signée Yannick aléno pour
poursuivre des fromages français et
anglais enfin en dessert lisent pas en
de Pierre Hermé un macaron avec sa crème
parfumée à la rose agrémentée de
framboises fraîches et de litchi puis de
150 invités prendront place à table
parmi lesquels Mick Jagger Charlotte
Gainsbourg ou encore Hugh Grant
[Musique]
la reine Elizabeth est venue à
Versailles en 1957 à l'invitation du
président Coty et c'était c'était un
moment très important ça a été peut-être
la première grande visite d'État de la
prière et elle en avait profité pour
inaugurer l'Opéra Royal de Versailles
qui avait été entièrement entièrement
restauré par Jappy à l'époque et puis
elle a résidé aussi non pas à Versailles
même mais dans le domaine au Grand
Trianon à l'époque où le général de
Gaulier élan ayant fait complètement
restauré l'aile de tri-annonce ou bois
pour y accueillir des chefs d'État le
président Pompidou l'avait installé là
pour un une visite qui était semi privée
semi-officiel le prince Charles qui
maintenant est le roi Charles III
connaît bien le château de Versailles
aussi où il a eu l'occasion évidemment
de venir à plusieurs reprises
le château de Versailles vous savez
c'est un peu la salle des fêtes de la
République c'est ce qu'avait oublié les
présidents Chirac Sarkozy et Hollande
avant eux nombreux ont été les chefs
d'État qui se sont
centices chez eux à Versailles on
raconte toujours une anecdote je ne sais
pas si elle est vraie mais on raconte
que le général de Gaulle un jour vient à
Versailles pour recevoir le Roi Baudouin
et la reine Fabiola il s'installe dans
le petit appartement de jour qui avait
été
aménagé pour lui en attendant l'arrivée
des souverains belges et Madame
vanderchem qui était américaine qui
était l'épouse de Gérald vanderkem lui
dit mon Général sentez-vous chez vous et
il paraît que de Gaulle lui avait
rétorqué du tac au tac mais madame je
suis chez moi et c'est vrai que d'une
certaine manière on doit pouvoir dire
que à Versailles la République est dans
ses meubles
[Musique]
oui alors vous savez j'ai fait un livre
moi là-dessus qui s'appelle le
Versailles après les rois qui racontent
tout ce qui est devenu le château de
Versailles à partir de la Révolution et
jusqu'à nos jours et on se rend compte
que Versailles n'a jamais cessé d'être
au cœur même de toutes les solennités du
pays que l'on soit sous l'Empire que
l'on soit sous la monarchie restaurée
des frères de Louis XVI sous la
Monarchie de Juillet à l'époque de
Louis-Philippe sous le Second Empire
bien sûr puisque c'est notamment qui a
été reçu la reine Victoria et le prince
Albert en 55 et d'ailleurs je crois que
on évoquera cette réception fastueuse de
la reine Victoria à Versailles pendant
la visite du roi Charles III et puis
ensuite bien sûr pendant les différentes
républiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui oui ça n'a rien à voir avec le
statut de souverain ou non alors c'est
vrai que le général de Gaulle lorsqu'il
a décidé d'utiliser le château de
Versailles pour les grandes solennités
de la République je vous ai parlé du Roi
Baudouin il a reçu également le
président Kennedy avait l'intention de
donner à cette
assez comment dire à ce château à cette
réception particulière à Versailles un
statut
spécifique il voulait d'une certaine
manière honorée particulièrement les
grands hôtes de la France en visite
d'État par la suite le président
Pompidou a plusieurs reprises et surtout
le président Giscard d'Estaing qui a
fait un grand usage de Versailles ont un
peu étendu l'utilisation du château on
se rappelle notamment la très grande
réception qui avait donné le président
Giscard d'Estaing pour le chat d'Iran et
et la chabanoué et Farah Diba et puis il
y a eu donc le sommet de Versailles de
1982 ne l'oublions pas ou le président
Mitterrand a redonné d'une certaine
manière à Versailles une place centrale
puisque le monde entier avait les yeux
rivés sur ce qui à l'époque était la
réunion du G7 avec Ronald Reagan avec
Margaret Thatcher avec toutes les avec
tous les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
de cette époque du début des années 80
et c'est le président Chirac qui
par un républicanisme peut-être mal
placé je n'en sais rien et il semblerait
que ce soit d'ailleurs sur les conseils
de sa fille Claude en tout cas c'est ce
que j'ai entendu dire ça je ne pourrais
pas le prouver c'est lui qui a décidé de
mettre un peu Versailles au rangard pour
répondre à votre question complètement
Patrice c'est vrai que Versailles a été
un lieu très important pour l'histoire
de la République ne serait-ce que parce
que
à partir de 1871 avec les prodromes de
la Commune de Paris le président de
l'exécutif à l'époque le chef de
l'exécutif Adolphe Thiers avait fait
venir l'ensemble des services
gouvernementaux et des corps constitués
à Versailles ainsi que le Parlement
l'assemblée de l'époque l'assemblée des
urnes de février 71 et il avait rapatrié
l'assemblée depuis enfin on disait à
l'époque la chambre depuis Bordeaux
jusqu'à Versailles à partir du moment où
le régime est devenu bicaméral on a
installé le Sénat dans l'ancienne Opéra
royal et pour la Chambre des députés on
a construit le grand hémicycle d'Edmond
Joly dans dans l'aile du Midi et c'est à
ce moment-là évidemment que Versailles
est devenu un lieu parlementaire et ce
qui est amusant intéressant c'est que
des Mac Macron les présidents sont
rentrés à l'Élysée les corps constitués
sont revenus à Paris mais les
parlementaires prudents sont restés à
Versailles jusqu'en 1879 ce qui veut
dire que au moment du vote du régime ce
qu'on appelle l'amendement vallon en
1875 c'est bien à Versailles que
l'amendement vallon a été pris donc la
Troisième République ancêtre de la
quatrième et de la 5ème nos républiques
sont nés à Versailles et c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps jusqu'en 1962 tous les
présidents de la République ont été élus
à Versailles y compris je me permets de
le rappeler le général de Gaulle pour
son premier mandat
ça me fait penser à cette très jolie
scène extrait d'un film de Sacha Guitry
qui s'appelle en montant les
Champs-Élysées où l'on voit un certain
nombre d'activistes sur des murs de
Paris écrire à la craie vive le roi
c'est rayé vive la nation c'est rayé
vive l'Empereur et vive le Roi et vive
l'Empereur et un moment Sacha Guitry et
que ça blouse de maître d'école arrive
il efface tout ça il écrit vive la
France il se retourne vers le public et
il dit c'est tellement plus simple
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines il y aura-t-il l'ouverture
d'une commission d'enquête pour le jeune
Nicolas à Poissy c'est en tout cas ce
que propose la députée les républicains
des Alpes-Maritimes Christelle d'interny
pour mettre en lumière toutes les
circonstances du drame qui ont poussé au
suicide de l'adolescence scolarisé à
Poissy le 5 septembre dernier après
plusieurs autres villes françaises
Poissy n'a pas été épargné par la
multiplication des fausses alertes à la
bombe qui touchent des établissements
scolaires depuis lundi mardi c'est le
lycée Charles de Gaulle qui a été pris
pour cible aux alentours de 14h les 1131
élèves ont été évacués de leur
établissement rapidement un lourd
dispositif policier a été mis en place
pour évacuer et sécuriser les lieux les
cours ont finalement repris en fin
d'après-midi une fois le doute levé
Guyancourt solidaire avec le Maroc et la
Libye François Morton le maire de la
commune a annoncé proposé au prochain
conseil municipal que soit versé à la
Fondation de France ainsi que 3000 euros
à la Croix-Rouge française ces sommes
serviront à venir en aide aux victimes
on termine par du golf les Green du Golf
National de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sont prêts pour accueillir l'Open de
France de golf 2023 la compétition
débute ce jeudi 21 septembre et se
terminera ce dimanche plusieurs favoris
se dégagent pour ce rendez-vous
l'Américain Billy yorkshell et surtout
le jeune prodige sud-coré un Tom Kim du
côté des Français livelinois Antoine
Rosner sera aussi de la partie
[Musique]
la prostate c'est une glande qui se
trouve sous la vessie et qui va servir à
fabriquer la majorité du liquide séminal
et en fait elle a la particularité
d'être au carrefour
urogénitale et voilà
c'est que les hommes qui ont une
prostate les femmes n'en ont pas
[Musique]
platénome de prostate c'est juste
l'augmentation du volume de la glande et
qui va venir gêner finalement
l'écoulement des urines et c'est ce dont
se plaint majorité des patients qui vont
venir voir l'urologue c'est plutôt avoir
des troubles urinaires la deuxième
pathologie c'est le cancer de prostate
et pour lequel la majorité des patients
vont pas avoir de symptômes mais il se
soigne très bien en fait on a une
incidence qui est à peu près stable avec
des taux de mortalité qui sont plutôt en
baisse notamment justement par rapport
au dépistage précoce
[Musique]
les recommandations de dépistage pour
une population générale c'est à partir
de 50 ans mais si vous avez dans vos
identités familiaux plusieurs cancers de
prostate des cancer du siens chez
plusieurs apparentés ou une origine
aussi afro antillaise en fait il va
falloir faire un dépistage plus précoce
qui peut commencer à 45 voire 40 ans en
fonction des facteurs de risque
familiaux
[Musique]
allez réagissez un petit peu loin
voilà c'est ça des frappes intenses de
la rapidité à 30 ans Philippines Pereira
Lopez a une nouvelle fois fait briller
les couleurs de son club le gantor de
Huy après un titre mondial en 2022 le 2
septembre dernier livre linoise membre
de l'équipe de France a remporté le
titre de championne d'Europe assault de
boxe française dans la catégorie des
moins de 65 kg la compétition c'est
plutôt bien passée grâce à l'expérience
que j'avais eu déjà en septembre 2022
sur les championnats du monde j'avais un
peu moins de stress ou alors j'apprends
à mieux gérer au fur et à mesure aussi
ce stress on est très encadré avec
l'équipe de France on n'est pas seul il
y a les autres les autres athlètes donc
c'est un soutien moi j'ai mes coachs qui
m'ont accompagné jusqu'en Croatie
Sandrine et Stéphane qui sont venus pour
me soutenir il y avait mon père il y
avait des amis des membres ici du club
qui sont venus aussi qui ont fait le
déplacement donc c'est un soutien de les
voir c'est une force
bien fermée
te plante pas sur ta jambe te plante pas
sur ta jambe
des soutiens qui l'ont mené vers les
sommets de la discipline bien qu'elle
domine sa catégorie la boxeuse n'est pas
dispensée d'entraînement sous l'oeil
bienveillant mais intransigeant de
l'ancienne championne du monde Sandrine
Mathilde si tu le vois avancer sur le
dernier coup de pied il faut que tu
chasses d'accord
mais si tu mets le fouetter tu vas te
retrouver en faute donc là tu as vu tu
l'as fait comme il faut au programme du
jour 1h30 d'entraînement sur le ring ou
au sac si la discipline n'est pas
inscrite aux Jeux Olympiques un autre
événement attend très prochainement la
sportive j'ai une nouvelle échéance qui
arrive au mois d'octobre j'ai été
sélectionnée par la Fédée pour aller au
Liban pour un tournoi international le
fait de pouvoir tourner comme ça à
l'international avec des personnes que
j'ai pas l'habitude de boxer ça me
permet aussi de me de me connaître un
peu mieux sur ma réaction sur voilà
comment je réagis comment je m'adapte
toutes ces choses en fait
parallèlement j'apprends beaucoup sur
moi en boxant pour arriver à ce niveau
du travail mais aussi un accompagnement
permanent depuis plus de 10 ans tout un
collectif se mobilise pour la soutenir
il y a vraiment un travail d'équipe
c'est à dire que elle est obligée
d'avoir des partenaires pour s'entraîner
et il y a vraiment un partenariat de
tout le monde c'est un sport qui qui
commande vraiment beaucoup de
d'implication pour beaucoup de monde
pour que Philippines y arrive voilà et
c'est il y a un travail d'elle-même mais
il y a aussi tout l'entourage qui compte
dans quelques jours Philippines
s'envolera pour le Liban avec une partie
de l'équipe de France l'occasion
d'améliorer encore ses performances et
de porter les couleurs de la France sans
oublier son club
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je présente le parrain un
film de Francis Ford Coppola de 1972
écrit par Mario Puzzo et adapté du livre
qu'il avait aussi lui-même écrit
évidemment au-delà d'un thème qu'on ne
présente plus et que la musique que tout
le monde a entendu même sans avoir vu le
film
[Musique]
le parrain c'est
considéré comme souvent d'ailleurs
derrière cette zone game comme le
deuxième meilleur jeu de tous les temps
le parrain suis le parcours de Michael
kornéon joué par un passionneau de tout
jeune qui au début du film ne veut
absolument rien à voir avec sa famille
de mafieux
menée par Don Corleone par un Marlon
Brodeau incroyable couvert de prothèses
méconnaissable ou le studio d'ailleurs
s'est battu contre Coppola ce qu'il ne
voulait pas d'un Brodeau qui était jugé
ingérable sur un plateau et Copa était
battu pour dire il faut vraiment me
Brando et aujourd'hui on peut pas
imaginer le film sans ballon de Brando
dans ce rôle là et donc son ascension
dans dans cette mafia le film a une
histoire grand-combolique sur la il y a
eu une série qui est sorti à pas
longtemps il y a offert sur le comment
ce film est écrit mais la voiture du
producteur avait été avait été criblée
de balle pour leur faire peur il y a eu
des menaces Coppola raconte que son
téléphone sonnait parfois la nuit avec
personne au bout du film ou juste une
respiration un film rempli de mystères
et de mythes en tout cas autour la mafia
à l'époque en tout cas il y a des
pressions pour que le mot mafia causea
Nostrad n'apparaisse pas dans le film
dans le scénario donc il avait été
retiré c'est un film tellement
intemporel et c'est quand même le film
qui a lancé tous les films sur la mafia
et sur le crime résumé aujourd'hui on a
aucun film aujourd'hui sur cette
thématique là qui existerait sans le
parrain tous les codes sont là que soit
l'atmosphère que ce soit les codes la
mafia en costume cravate tout ça c'est
le parrain qu'il a montré en premier et
ce sont des images qui sont tellement
dans l'imaginaire collectif qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer aujourd'hui un film de
gangster sans penser aux parents c'est
un film long il faut s'accrocher c'est
un film différente de ce qu'on ferait
aujourd'hui en termes de rythme il y a
une pression de la mise en scène il y a
pas un plan qui est pas là où il devrait
être et surtout voilà Pacino dans dans
peut-être le rôle de sa vie donc un film
à voir le parrain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain matin prenez bien votre parapluie
le département des Yvelines se
réveillera sous la grisaille et la pluie
au niveau des températures il fera 15
degrés à Rambouillet 16 à Houdan et
Versailles et 17 à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi nous devrions avoir des
éclaircies mais ponctués tout de même de
quelques averses côté température même
tendance que durant la matinée 16 degrés
à Versailles et Rambouillet et 17 à
Houdan et Mantes-la-Jolie et demain nous
fêterons la saint Matthieu et ce sera
également le premier jour de l'automne
tout de suite l'invité du 7 8 avec
Régine rallès
[Musique]
sensibiliser à la transition écologique
c'est l'objectif que se donne la
communauté d'agglomération de
Rambouillet territoire le samedi 23
septembre se tiendra la journée du
développement durable à la Bergerie
nationale et pour en parler avec nous
Thomas gourland bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes le président de Rambouillet
territoire pourquoi est-ce que c'est
important d'organiser ce type de journée
parce que il faut sensibiliser les
enjeux environnementaux les enjeux de
qualité de vie de préservation de
l'environnement sont maintenant majeurs
plus personne n'en doute et le rôle de
l'agglomération de Rambouillet
territoire c'est justement de faire en
sorte d'encore plus expliquer les enjeux
sensibiliser les personnes et surtout
faire bouger les gestes quotidien pour
enfin pouvoir agir et alors quel type
d'animation qu'on va pouvoir retrouver à
ces journées le maître mot de ses
journées c'est l'interactivité et le
côté ludique il faut à la fois qu'on
puisse pratiquer qu'on puisse
expérimenter puis aussi apprendre de
manière ludique sans s'ennuyer c'est ça
les deux grandes thématiques et nous
aurons quatre grands quatre grands
ateliers qui seront faits sur ces sur
ces trois journées et alors
l'environnement c'est un des enjeux dont
on parle le plus aujourd'hui dans notre
société est-ce que c'est un événement
qui rassemble chaque année effectivement
on a eu un grand succès l'année dernière
on a fait la première édition des
Journées du développement durable compte
tenu de la fréquentation que nous avons
eu on a considéré j'ai considéré qu'il
fallait évidemment le reconduire et donc
on a maintenant changé de lieu et on est
ici à la Bergerie Nationale dont je
remercie encore la directrice et
l'ensemble de ces de ces agents pour
leur accueil et cet événement à quel
type de public et ce qui s'adresse
exactement parce qu'on sait que les
jeunes se saisissent assez facilement de
ce type de sujet est-ce que ça attire
aussi les adultes ou les seniors
effectivement les jeunes sont un
excellent vecteur pour transmettre les
messages environnementaux et les bonnes
pratiques donc nous aurons deux
premières journées le jeudi et le
vendredi ou les accueillons les classes
de CM1 et CM2 du territoire qui
viendront sur deux journées pratiquées
l'ensemble des ateliers et on espère que
finalement qui vient feront venir entre
parent sur la journée du samedi on sait
que les enfants sont des influenceurs
mais et vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
donc quatre grands thèmes rythmeront
cette journée donc le cycle de l'eau la
biodiversité la gestion des déchets et
la biodiversité et la mobilité pardon
alors dans la partie biodiversité cette
année il y aura des apiculteurs est-ce
que c'est important de les convier de
les mettre en avant alors c'est très
important et ça fait plusieurs années
que nous travaillons avec le canif le
conservatoire de la baignoire
d'Île-de-France puisque nous avons 36
rue chez qui sont disposés sur
l'ensemble du territoire cruchet
représentant une commune de Rambouillet
territoire le canif
œuvre tous les jours toute l'année pour
la conservation de cet abbé noir on sait
bien que l'abeille est absolument
essentielle en terme de préservation
d'environnement puisqu'elle participe à
la pollinisation et donc il faut
absolument agir en ce sens et c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont là ils sont évidemment
les bienvenus et il y aura aussi
beaucoup de jeux est-ce que c'est un
moyen aussi
d'aborder l'environnement de manière
plus ludique parce que c'est vrai que
quand on en parle c'est critique il y a
deux leviers dans le côté ludique des
choses la première chose c'est qu'on
sait bien que tous autant qu'on est
lorsqu'on approche les choses de manière
sous l'angle du jeu on apprend plus
facilement et plus aisément mais aussi
derrière cela c'est aussi de montrer que
les enjeux écologiques c'est pas
forcément que de l'anxiété c'est aussi
des perspectives c'est aussi des
possibilités de changer les choses et
c'est ces deux volets là que l'aspect
ludique apporte alors on est obligé d'en
parler par rapport à l'actualité d'hier
on a l'Organisation météorologique
mondiale qui indique que les objectifs
qui étaient fixés pour 2030 en termes de
développement durable ne seront pas
atteints malheureusement est-ce que vous
sentez que les citoyens aujourd'hui
peuvent aussi désespérer et se dire que
les gestes du quotidien comme vous
l'aviez dit tout à l'heure sont
peut-être un peu trop minimes le maître
mot enfin l'approche que je porte en
termes de gestion des sujets de
l'environnementaux c'est une approche
positive et une approche
comment dirais-je de progrès et de
résolution des problèmes il faut pas
avoir une anxiété par rapport à ça et se
recroqueviller au contraire il faut se
saisir des sujets et les approcher de
manière rationnelle scientifique et
positive encore une fois pour pouvoir
les résoudre donc c'est tout l'enjeu de
ces journées de développement durable
c'est montrer que nous pouvons agir
chacun de nous au quotidien dans nos
gestes quotidiens dans dans
l'environnement dans lequel nous sommes
et c'est
itérativement lorsque chacun aura mis la
pâte comme tout le monde maintenant est
engagé dans cette technique là je suis
certain que nous allons réussir et
d'ailleurs vous êtes aussi vous très
actif sur la question vous aviez saisi
ces sujets notamment via l'Agenda 21 ou
le plan climat air énergie territoriale
est-ce que ces journées c'est aussi
l'occasion de montrer que le territoire
est actif quant à ces sujets que voilà
vous vous êtes très actif sur cette
question exactement en fait vous avez
merci de le mentionner l'Agenda 21 et le
plan climat air énergie territoriale ont
été votées et mis en action par embêté
territoire l'ensemble des services de
Rambouillet territoire sont mobilisés
sur ces trois journées le service du
cycle de l'eau le service de la gestion
des milieux la pratique nos partenaires
que sont le SICTOM et si très bas pour
le traitement des ordures ménagères
notre service de mobilité ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que cet agenda 21 et
ce plan climat air énergétique
territorial il se traduit concrètement
depuis déjà de nombreux mois et l'objet
de cette de ces journées c'est de
montrer ce que nous avons déjà fait et
ce qui reste encore à faire alors pour
cette journée du 23 septembre vous vous
attendez combien de personnes le maximum
j'espère que tu en sera avec nous comme
il l'est aujourd'hui compte tenu du
succès que nous avons eu l'année
dernière et de la sensibilité que
l'ensemble des personnes ont eu partant
des habitants du territoire haut je suis
certain que nous serons débordés et bien
alors si vous aussi vous souhaitez
participer à cet événement sachez qu'il
est gratuit et c'est samedi 23 septembre
de 11h à 18h voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup Thomas gourland
d'avoir accepté de nous accorder cet
entretien en attendant le 23 septembre
je vous souhaite de passer une
excellente soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]